we have back here on the show one of the
best pass rushers in the National
Football League three-time Pro Bowler
and a man who was I did not know that he
has to flip phones himself Cameron
Jordan here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Cameron that's not true you saw
one on Sunday did you not oh yeah oh
yeah that's something that okay - my
Thomas's flip phone that's right here
before we get to that let's let's talk
about what you know I thought it was the
biggest statement win of the year I'm
wondering what you and the Saints
thought of it Cameron I mean I love that
way and I love that you know we've been
able to put seven straight together
we've been able to travel well on the
road and defend our dome so when you
come down to it I'd love to continue the
street no I know but I just do you think
it serves notice on the rest of the
league here or what do you think it
can't just be just any old window right
yeah I mean we talked about the Rams
that was something that we had on our
mind especially since they were eight no
but we're treating every week like it's
it's it's the most important game of our
year because the next important game
over here I'm not gonna make anything
more of it other than you know we got it
we got a hard one coming up this
upcoming week so what did you what were
you able to do against Todd Gurley that
the rest of the league seems to have a
problem doing Cameron I'm honestly you
know I after looking at the film it was
like first now you know he maybe get a
yard or two and we put out the hits on
him early but at the same time he still
had you know four or five plays where he
broke and showed how special he is this
there's not much you can do to really
stop TV other than to rally to the ball
and I think we did just that but that
was the game plan right at number 30
that was the that was the one you wanted
to stop for sure for sure when you talk
about what what they have on a team we
talked about Jared Goff Brandon cooks
Todd Gurley you clearly see the engine
the motor being cogs early so that's
something we had to try and try and put
a stamp on did you connect with cooks
before the game after the game former
team minutes yeah after the game of
course I mean that's that's when the you
know brothers that's been through the
fire with me I'm always gonna have love
for four young cooks and I'm
I'm glad that he found a home out in LA
and you know I'm glad he also took home
that hell alright so now let's get to
your your current guy who can't be
guarded I mean this kid's special
Michael Thomas what did you think though
of the cellphone being pulled out I
thought it was hilarious and I was
wondering who gave this man a flip phone
male where do they do they sell flip
phones anymore um you know so many
thoughts come to mind but when you have
it a game like that you know he's paying
home is it to one of uh one of these
things great I love it no I I will
follow up though here okay and I know
that I will follow up being accused of
me being somebody's a stick-in-the-mud
or anything like that but that 15-yard
penalty put you right on a short field I
mean that that's your defense that
you've got to go back out there and try
and stop the Rams who are is a team that
can score pretty fast regardless of how
good you might be you didn't think that
at all um not at all we need to talk
about the momentum that we had going
forward and you know as the game went on
we felt like we had a pretty good touch
on what their office was trying to do so
honestly you think that we were more we
were more energized to take the field
again especially we had already created
a turnover so yeah we had everything
going in for for us and we believed in
ourselves and they paid off and and
let's talk about what a kid he is
Michael Thomas it kind of was out of
character in a way I mean and the thing
that I was pointing out yesterday is
it's so difficult to stop him because he
catches everything that's thrown his way
and he's got the most accurate passer in
the history league throwing to him I
mean I'm wondering what it's like
watching this from your perspective it
was uncharacteristic the flip of the
phone yeah just the flash you know what
I mean like he in a few times that I've
gotten to meet him he doesn't strike me
as a diva receiver you know no he's
definitely not that when you talk about
Mike T he's all about the hard-working
effort that he put towards right you
know the flip phone was sort that was
that was sort of funny it like I said if
anything that sort of energized the rest
of the team re-energized Rusted team for
everything that you know heat
Fortin into that effort right there I
mean the placement of the phone -
pulling the phone out the flip and at
the end of day you know he comes out to
be one of the best receivers and he
improves it every week he's terrific
there's there of that there is no doubt
Cameron Jordan of the Saints here on the
Rich Eisen show okay so now moving
forward here Cameron your team you've
got this week coming up for the New
Orleans Saints you are at home I know
you're actually at Cincinnati right now
what is what are the challenges that you
think faces you here so you figured Joe
Mixon is running at a high level I don't
know if AJ's playing this week or not
and if he is I mean that's the top-tier
receiver right there you talk about what
you know what they've been able to do
they're not they're definitely not any
slump of a team they're a team that's
been winning and when you talk about the
power do they have a deal on that do you
think with with Gino Atkins and Carlos
Dunlap this is something that you know
we have to we have to overcome and
Marcus Davenport last time you were on
about a month ago you're telling me
about how you were mentoring this kid
and it's just seemed like he was
beginning to to get some steam going in
his rookie year and now he's got a foot
injury what impact does that have on the
defensive line Cameron you know I think
we still have depth at that defensive
line and we talked about Margaret
Davenport went down but you have Trey
Henderson who who has been doing nothing
but honing his craft waiting for a
chance and we gave him that and I think
he's showing he's shown that he's trying
to become a polished pass rusher you
talk about what Alex over for bridge
said table you know the thing about us
is we always had that next man up
mentality and when Marcus comes back in
the rotation will he be geared and ready
to go and I've got Kareem Jackson coming
on shortly Cameron from the Texans I'm
gonna ask him this later on he started
on three and they ripped off six in a
row and their seasons completely turned
around you weren't in that big of a hole
at all but a home loss to start the
season Ryan Fitzpatrick came in and just
absolutely tore it all up I'm wondering
what what what happened in weeks one a
week to that you were able to put your
foot in the ground
who was holding it together and that may
be moment of doubt early on in the
season for you guys was there a moment
of doubt I mean you know if anything if
you just look at last season where we
started off oh and - and then put
together a string of eight wins what was
there to be doubtful about you talk
about you know last year we had so many
rookies playing for us now they're
second years there is nothing but
confidence of hey we we can we can put
these wins together
and now you need it that first win is
falling in it out from outside buildings
we think we think the sky is falling
Cameron no doubt you know I'm a couple
of seasons back back when was the
Packers were Oh in three year over four
at the time and Aaron Rodgers did calm
down you know this is this is a season
it's not it's not death by every game
can they went ahead and went to the
playoffs we have we have the same
mentality in terms of you know what the
first game is going to define us but you
know by midseason you're going to know
what we're about and sitting at
midseason I'm gonna let you figure out
what we're about
okay so now I'm gonna let you maybe play
a news reporter for a second for me if
you don't mind being a Rich Eisen show
correspondent for the moment did you see
Dez Bryant in the building was he around
today I think yeah I think so yes have
you so you have not seen Dez Bryant in
the building
nope my off day today's been an eventful
off day for me
QuickLIFT okay steam room you know I'll
get a massage a little later on to get
the body back okay
I have not I've not seen death today so
Dez didn't ask to work in on your left
what you're saying yeah I guess I guess
I was too focused on myself that okay
how dare I take my off day to myself
okay so that's what you've got so you'd
lift steam massage I'll be a great dad
today I'm honored you work this show
into that schedule I appreciate that
yeah I mean I'm I'm actually bummed that
I'm not in Phoenix voting right now for
some reason my you know my mail-in
ballot didn't come in and it's dawned on
me Friday I was like what was the
situation doing I've got to be able to
vote reached out to come people and like
look
you know a couple people my family
didn't get the mail in Bali at least
they're in Arizona to vote and so now
I'm just you know I'm sort of perturbed
that I said needed vote today so I'm
just a little perturbed at the day's
events
mm-hmm so you you're you did not get a
ballot in Louisiana is that what you're
saying or do you know Arizona I'm a home
resident of Arizona you know we split
time okay as much as I might as I love
Louisiana Arizona raised me and that's
where I've been voting but that might I
might turn around and have to become a
Louisiana resident for real okay three
kids from Louisiana no mark now in
Louisiana it is what it is mm-hmm okay
all three kids there in Louisiana all
right Cameron have you noticed that the
rest of the league is celebrating posing
as a defensive unit after big plays have
you picked up on that yeah I feel like I
just said last week but you know I feel
I feel that emulation is a form of
flattery and we talk about what our
defense has been able to do and getting
the ball back so often we'll go from
there so you don't you you don't say
that's our thing that's what was our
thing we were definitely I definitely
did at the same time I'm unfazed we've
got things that we have to accomplish so
I can't be worried about everybody else
okay Cameron you've got aa look and
you're locked in I mean you know I like
it you've you stick to side all of these
sub positions that I've thrown you away
about doubt after week one about you
know Michael Thomas perhaps putting you
guys in a bind and III appreciate you
coming on and just firing away like that
as always hey I locker room is strong
you know the love we have for our
teammates is strong and the belief that
we have to to go ahead and make this a
great season
it's strong so at any time you know
we're always ready for smoke is it true
that last one for you that your coach
Sean Payton brought in the Purdue mascot
or at least the Purdue mascot head to
taunt the Ohio State Buckeyes that dot
all over your defense is that a true
story Cameron I have I'm gonna have to
please a fit on this facility okay
but may or may not have been a little
bit of ribbing or jamming you're
speculating that our head coach has some
high sense of humor that you know the
world is unbeknownst to that's something
that you'll just have to continue
speculating you know as for the building
we know what happens oh man this is
you're a politician on election day I
love it hey Cameron thanks for calling
and really appreciate it what much
thanks for having me going you bet as
always at cam Jordan 90 for the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience